why don't we start with the with the
take that has launched a thousand a
thousand takes and that is your take on
pornography's over the past few weeks
there's been this widespread debate that
was launched because you talked about
the outlawing of pornography at the
federal level first of all I you lay out
your position on what exactly federal
law should be with regard to pornography
yeah I think well there's I mean there's
two things there's what we could
practically actually do and there's
there's ideally what should be done and
I recognize that those two things are
separate here because I don't think
there could be a federal law just
banning all pornography right now
especially with the way Supreme Court
has decided on this I think that there's
I think that there should be I like it
if the Lord just like with abortion I'd
like that as well but there can't be
because the Supreme Court I think what
practically could be done are enforcing
just like those what it really started
this was the letter from the few
Republicans urging their department
justice to just enforce of sanity laws
that are on the books I think that could
be a good step and then even even
further things like you know an opt-in
option like some countries have to call
your service provider opt-in if you want
pornographic content segregate the
content to a separate part X X domain
things like that and things you know
requiring and maybe you have to present
ID or some sort of identification
information is on accesses material
these are things are basic steps that
would at a minimum protect children
because that's been my focus with this
is that children are exposed to this so
much and the effect that has on them
psychologically and emotionally and in
so many other ways
I totally agree with this actually I
mean I wrote an entire book back in 2005
to went largely ignored called porn
generation about the impact that
pornography was having on young men in
particularly the desensitization of men
to how women ought to be treated turning
them into basically a series of body
parts as opposed to treating them as
holistic human beings how this is part
of the generalized sexual revolution so
one of the things that it's been
puzzling man has been sort of the
breakdown to me between conservatives
and libertarians over this issue I
consider myself more libertarian on
governmental issues but I don't think
that the government has no role to play
in protecting children from pornography
and in fact I don't even think you need
to make a in anti libertarian case in
order to argue
that pornography has significant
externalities particularly with with
regard to to children and sort of
puzzled by so many libertarians are anti
cracking down on hardcore pornography
distribution to kids under 18 for
example yeah especially those who would
still identify in some way as
conservative because the thing is
obviously you know if this case was
being made 30 years ago if anything like
internet porn existed 30 years ago like
it does today and and they were
conservative saying hey we need to crack
down on this it pretty much everyone who
calls himself a conservative 30 years
ago would have at least taken that
argument seriously maybe maybe not all
of all agreed but but but these days now
you have conservatives just recoiling
and hard the very notion that the
government would do anything about it
and that I find absurd and I agree with
you know there's this interesting
discussion about you know is the
government to protect the common good or
is about observing liberties and I think
that's an interesting discussion and
fascinating and and and we could have
that debate but I think that we don't
even need really to get into that
because this if you focus along the fact
that children are exposed to it and
because people like to say well you know
people consent that people choose to
pursue this content they consent to
seeing it so there's no role for the
government well I would say that
children cannot consent you know that's
why we say that if an adult has such a
child it's rape automatically no matter
what the child said because a child does
not have the emotional and psychological
capacity to consent and if the child
can't consent to be a second party
participant in a sexual act I would say
they can't consent to be a third party
as a witness so every time a child is
exposed to pornography I would say
they're being essentially accused by the
person who put it on the Internet
knowing that a child could access now
well this did lead to a broader debate
and this one I think is actually pretty
important inside the conservative
movement right now between conservatives
and libertarians over the role of
government not again because of the
views on pornography you and I agree on
the evils of pornography but with regard
to the role of government generally so
I've contrasted in the past when I've
called common good conservatism with
rights-based conservatism and a lot of
folks on the right these days we're
talking about quote-unquote common good
conservatism basically the idea that the
government exists to promote the common
good to act as a teacher to act as a
moral arbiter I've been very wary of
that simply because I believe that the
best role for government is to stay
pretty much out of everybody's life so
far as you're not invading anybody
else's rights and that the role of
social institutions like churches is to
fill that gap and that we ought to be
strengthening those social institutions
we ought to put our hearts and souls
into doing nap at the moment you grant
government extra power to quote unquote
do what you want then you are also
granting the bad guys on the other side
the power to use that power against you
and I'm much more fearful the left is
going to use government power to invade
the rights of religious people than to
defend the rights of religious people
yeah I think the way that I would try to
split the baby there is I would agree
with you that saying the government's
primary role or one of its primary roles
is to be a moral teacher that is a
little troubling for I think obvious
reasons and so I understand that
argument but at the same time I do think
that the government's fundamental the
fundamental reason why the government
exists the reason why governments are
instituted in the first place is to
facilitate and preserve the common good
and and and if we say well no it's about
preserving rights well but why why does
it matter why why why should the
government preserve rights
why do rights matter well the only
reason it matters is because it's good
it's right that's that's so I would say
that's part of the common good I don't I
guess my point is I don't see how we
separate rights from the common good I
think they're a package deal and the
good is even more fundamental it lies
beneath as a foundation for for human
rights so that's right so that
individual rights are part of the common
good the problem is that when the
government is in charge of both the
common good and protecting individual
rights the government is in conflict
with itself all the time and so the the
way that the founders and I believe drew
this out was that the government was
there to protect individual rights and
social institutions were there to
protect the common good I'm also very
very doubtful that the government has
the capacity to act in the interests of
preserving for example religious values
or even conservative social mores the
government has actually done a horrible
job of doing that and in fact has
invaded those social mores the more
government you grant to a power more
power you grant to a government to do
that the harder that's going to become
particularly on the federal level when
you get to the local level I have some
more cross
over an agreement with you you know I
think that if a local government wants
to go further than the national
government does that make some sense
given the fact that it's a more
homogeneous community it's actually you
can trust the government more at that
level then you can when you're talking
about a broad federal government when
you grant the broad federal government a
bigger government gun to go after stuff
that is in the quote-unquote common
interest more likely than that that is
going to be turned against the very
people who require the protection namely
religious communities yeah I guess I can
see that argument I don't really
disagree with anything you're saying I
guess what I would I would kind of agree
with what most libertarians say which is
the government has a role only when
other people are being harmed so if
you're doing something in your own home
and it's between consensual adults
there's nobody else around no one else
is being harmed by it then the
government really has no role and and
that's why I don't think the government
acts like a church or like an
institution like that where the church
does have something to say about the
things you do even in your home and no
one else the church has something to say
about things you think in your head
obviously we don't want the government
saying anything about that so yeah when
I think the government should step in
potentially when other people are being
harmed by a particular act my only my
difference that with a lot of
libertarians is that day they seem never
very limited to you sometimes of what
sorts of things harm other people and I
would argue that pornography
because of children and not just because
of that but other reasons as well is is
harmful is actually actively directly
harmful to other people and that's why
the government should step in
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content